lissa thank you so much for your
research you note yesterday I thought it
was uncommon ly valuable what struck me
is how everyone has left Nepal over the
last five or six years there's
essentially an export of their people
why is that
Tom Nepal has a difficult economic
situation it's got a difficult political
situation it's had you know they've come
out of an insurgency and in the last
successfully come out of an insurgency I
should say but in the last eight years
they've had seven prime ministers so
there's been a real issue with
governance and the economy has not done
what it can do to provide jobs for all
these people so you do see a lot of a
lot of young men and young women going
to the Gulf to work as guest workers
right
we saw Modi visit for the first time in
17 years last August did that change the
relationship and the outlook for Nepal
with India to the south I think that was
a very successful visit and I think it
did put Nepal India tais on a better
plane they had a little bit of a
difficult relationship over the years
and the policies India as the Big
Brother to the south as you can imagine
India's so much larger so that outreach
by Prime Minister Modi I think helped
bridge their ties and it's it seems to
be moving very well India's now taking
the lead on the International relief
effort in Nepal yeah elicit further
further than that issue does appear that
India is taking the lead sending
helicopters across the border with aid
but also China is involved and now China
is largest foreign investor in Nepal is
there a competition to you know bring
relief from these two countries well I'd
certainly say there's a geopolitical
competition writ large for influence in
Nepal but in this moment of crisis and
trying to help people to to rescue those
who are buried and try to provide
medical services to those who have been
rescued I wouldn't call this a
geopolitical competition at the moment
Alisa you open your article this weekend
folks I'll send it out on all my social
media lisajarrad the
ocean of your earthquake walk of a few
years ago describe that to us please
Nepal has been aware of the challenges
that it faces the seismic vulnerability
of being perched between these two
massive tectonic plates moving quickly
together colliding and the fact of this
rapid urban growth in Kathmandu itself
the city of about a million people and
people who have been focused on this
challenge of thinking about preparedness
for a big earthquake destined to happen
in the Kathmandu Valley have been
focused on it it's buildings and its
vulnerability to to breakage and
cracking and crumbling